we are moments away as we want to get
you live now to staple center russell
westbrook is now a laker
to um if you could keep your phones down
somewhat and not just stand up during
the press conference
and we'll be good and to wait till we
call on you to ask a question
and for the mic
all right we'll give it over to rob
this is an exciting day and appreciate
everybody being here in person um
there's a few people we want to thank
before we get into the formal
introduction of russell
first i wanted to thank
kyle kuzma
montrez harold and kcp
for their laker legacy legacies
two of those players of course are
champions with us and they'll always be
lakers so want to thank them for their
journey here
um wanted to thank
the washington wizards organization ted
leonsis and their general manager tommy
shepard
just for the spirit of collaboration and
professionalism
and and handling a transaction that was
seen as a win-win for both franchises
and then i wanted to also thank
thad fouche
russell's agent
just for his
role in all of this as well in his
spirit of collaboration once we made the
trade to onboard russell with our team
i think today is a
incredibly exciting day for the lakers
organization
to be sitting on the podium to introduce
one of the best playmakers that's ever
played in the game is
something where we feel incredibly
fortunate and blessed to do today
we had some goals this offseason as we
were
transitioning into
building our team and
two of the primary things we wanted to
address were adding another playmaker to
our roster
and then adding shooting and i think
over the last couple weeks i'm sure all
of you have seen
that we've been able to meet those goals
with um
you know with a lot of confidence and
today's about the playmaker piece i
think in thinking about russell
westbrook there's two things that come
to mind for me as a general manager
one is that
he's one of the most
liked and respected and beloved players
in the league by by players he's played
with
um he's an incredible leader and when
you talk to teammates from the other
storied franchises he's played for
to a man the input you get is that he's
one of the great teammates they've
played with and that speaks to his
character and his leadership and those
are qualities that are incredibly
important to our team
and then the second thing is
i think he is in an elite class of
players
in terms of his competitive nature
the one of the core qualities as we
build a roster is seeking out guys that
have an ultra
sense a heightened sense of being
competitive warriors on the court
players that played with the ultimate
um
sort of grit and grind and tenacity and
russell stands in an elite class in that
category
and that's drawn us to him
and then i would say the last thing that
i've really seen in the growth of his
game is
early in our careers i think all of us
when we're young we see certain we see
things a certain way and
a lot of his triple doubles early we're
done with force but i think now his
triple doubles are done with force and
with thoughtfulness and how he uses the
pieces and the players he plays with as
teammates and makes the sum of its the
parts greater than
each individual and i think he's really
learned
how to think the game at a higher level
so those are some of the qualities that
attracted us to this day and we're proud
to
introduce russell westbrook as a laker
and take your questions so thank you
first of all uh russell welcome back we
were just talking earlier about
when you were about 12 years old you
were watching the laker parades and
stuff like that
and even then you knew you wanted to be
a laker and how much this day means to
you the other part of the question is
in the past you've been used to being
the focal point of the offense now you
don't have to worry about that and what
adjustments will you make now that
you're playing with people uh like a.d
and lebron
oh i mean first man it's uh
surreal i think it still hasn't kind of
hit me yet that uh being from l.a
growing up
not too far from here being able to um
watch the parades
try to go to a mid school to try to go
to him
being a laker fan and
being from la but now
everything coming full circle for me is
a blessing you know it's a
lot of things i can't put into actual
words just because you know
some of these dreams don't come true for
people like myself
um and i'm truly blessed and thankful
uh for this opportunity and uh you know
i can't wait to get started um and then
secondly
um and we've
i've been blessed to be able to go into
my 14th season um and each year i try to
find ways
like rob mentioned to be able to
uplift and make my teammates better
around me um when a.d and brown are
friends of mine's first
and me being their teammate my job is to
come in and
uplift them and they'll do the same with
me vice versa
and as a season prolonged we will figure
it out it will be ups there will be
downs and that's
that's normal that's okay but we will
figure out uh how to play the best way
that we want to play to be able to win a
championship
oh uh kyle goon orange county register
um
russ i was just wondering
what it was like kind of talking to
lebron and a.d sort of getting a comfort
level that you guys could kind of work a
chemistry and a fit on and off the court
what were those conversations like and
and how did you get comfortable with the
idea that you guys could all play
together uh i mean honestly you know
we've
you know this stuff happened so quickly
this happened so fast uh you know last
two weeks or so
but we've had brief conversations and
talked about obviously what we need to
do and how we need to do that um and
we'll address that as training camp and
as the season comes along and we'll
figure it out
um when you went through this process
how draining was it how time was it and
how happy was your family that you got
back home to l.a
uh i mean it was uh you know anytime
a situation like this comes about
or an opportunity presents itself it's
all it can be stressful can be
a lot of emotions but ultimately um
the biggest thing for me is being in
this league when you know teams that
actually want you and actually
want you to be a place to me that means
more than anything else and at that
point it's my job to make sure that i
come in
and do
what i'm supposed to do and that's to
come and compete
and make sure that we have a chance to
compete for a championship
and yes my family was very very happy
hey russ welcome back to la when you
look at the way the league is kind of
shaping up right now where do you see
this team stacking up with some of these
other contenders and how
meaningful is it for you to be back in a
situation where you can say at the start
of the year that the goal is to win a
championship and that's potentially
attainable with this group yeah man to
be honest um my mindset is i never
really worry about no other team you
know to be honest i only can control
what's in our locker room um and how we
able to compete and go out and
i put our team up against anybody and
that's just kind of how my mindset is um
and that's where i stand with that
yeah russell do you feel like you have
anything to prove
uh no
i don't um
i've
been blessed and thankful to be able to
be in this league so long and
and lucky to be able to to play and be
healthy um
when i got drafted
in the nba um
that was me proving people wrong
when i was able to go to college and get
a degree that was me proving people not
a degree i wish i got a degree if i go
to college go to ucla from the inner
city that was me proving people wrong
just making it out the hood what's
proven people wrong i don't need to do
that anymore um i've been able to bless
the people around me my family
been able to impact people all across
the world with this platform that's been
given to me and i'm continuing to do
that and
obviously we want to win a championship
but ultimate goal is to make sure we use
what we have to impact others around you
hi russell mark we didn't hear usa today
congratulations good to see you
how do you initially envision how you
and lebron will share ball handling and
play-making duties
um you know
as you know brian is
one of the best players to play this
game
and
his ability to be able to kind of do
everything on the floor
allows me to be able to just figure it
out
i'm coming
to a championship caliber team and my
job is to make sure that i'm able to
make his game easy for him
and i'll find ways to do that throughout
the game
as it pertains to ball handling and all
that it really doesn't matter
there's many different ways you can
impact the game without having a ball in
your hands
and i've been able to do that for many
years and
i will figure it out
hey russ this is a i know you grew up in
l.a watching the lakers going to parades
and stuff you also had a really close
relationship with kobe bryant what what
you know did that do you have that in
your head at all when this trade was
coming together and in just these last
couple of weeks since it's happened yeah
i mean it hasn't left my head
um you know it's
things that we've talked about me and
him uh you know just
the potential of me being able to be a
laker and understanding what that
entails
um
and
you know it's just it's just
it's just crazy to think about you
know with me every time i put that laker
jersey on um
and
you know that's all i can say about that
okay we're gonna get a few questions on
zoom
okay we're gonna start off with uh my
trudeau
hey russ uh welcome to los angeles uh
just to follow up on kobe that there was
that time during his last year he came
to oklahoma city and you and k.d had
some time with him in the locker room
and kind of exchange gifts and it just
wondered the whole mentality he used to
talk about when he thought about you was
something that he that rob alluded to
that constant competitive fire um was
that the thing that he related to you
most with or did it just come from
competition and all the time that you
spent playing against him and so on and
talking to him um i think that was the
initial
um
thing that kind of brought us together
as being able to compete and
not be able to take nights off but we
beginning to have a better relationship
off the floor as brothers and and
talking about other things outside of
basketball
and things that we've been able connect
being able to do with this game and to
me that is
the most important thing i'm able to
cherish from kobe that i will continue
to cherish and live on
just an anecdote to that i remember i
still have his voice in my head but the
year that russell did the
broke the record that no one thought
would ever
be broken in terms of averaging a
triple-double and putting himself in the
category of players like the big o
i can just there were there were a small
handful of players
around the nba
that kobe really felt like embodied that
sort of mamba mentality and i remember
throughout that year
just his praise for russell's approach
and
you know him talking about
that competitive edge that is is rare in
sports across all sports and that
he
i could just hear him say he gets it
like he's got it
okay our next question will be from dave
mcmahon yes yeah
hi fellas i'm coming to you
uh start with ross i have a question for
rob as well
russ you've had so many moments in your
career whether it be that first round
series against the lakers obviously the
relationship with
uh kobe uh playing the lakers in the
bubble in the playoffs that uh nifty
hustle tribute game
melo spoke to us about how just the
lakers even though we never played for
them always seemed to be on his radar to
some extent i wondered if you could
uh speak to that did you share a type of
sentiment like that where you felt like
the lakers kind of circling in your
career um at some point um obviously
being from la you always wish that you
can play for your home team
and being able to do that
but that's definitely something that
always kind of circle around in my mind
and maybe one day but
i always will come back and be like ah
that would probably won't happen but you
know i just kind of wait to see if that
ever happened but now we're here and i'm
gonna take full advantage of it
and for rob
last season
the team certainly
was
decimated by injuries and that could
have been
the direction that you kind of came
to a conclusion on that hey if we had
health we can run it back
what motivated you to make such dramatic
changes this offseason
opportunity
i mean i think it was an opportunity to
make an aggressive
move that we felt like bettered our
probability to bring the 18th
title to the los angeles lakers
and when an opportunity like that comes
you're thoughtful
you analyze it
you look at the pros and cons and then
you you make a decision that's what
leaders are tasked to do and we felt
like this was an opportunity to
maximize our ability
to
do what we're obsessed to do and that's
to bring a 18th title to this city
thanks guys
all right thank you please okay we're
going to throw it back to you guys there
oh do you want to go ahead
okay sorry go ahead um
russell you've always been so adamant
about how challengers and boys and girls
club developed who you were as a young
man
now you get to come home and be the role
model for the young boys and girls who
are once where you or who are where you
once were what does that mean to you um
that is uh
kind of the most important thing about
being back home
being able to inspire and impact people
especially our youth in our
communities especially underserved
communities especially in the city of la
kind of where i grew up at and
my focus would be down into the
community
[Music]
like it's always been and i will
continue to find ways to
uplift our communities you know as much
as i can
hey russ haley winslow fox 11. welcome
back thank you appreciate it um you have
so many titles to be proud of what do
you think is the biggest thing you have
to offer to the lakers and then just for
fun what are you most looking forward to
off the court about being back home
um offered to like i mean i just
one thing i always
have done and always will do is stay
true to myself i think you can never
waver and i can never waver um in this
league um and what i've been in for a
long time and i always want to stay true
to who i am
but with that
making sure that i'm able to listen um
and be all ears because i am coming to
unbelievable organization team and
players that i'm able to learn from each
year i try to find
things i can learn and to be able to
help improve my game and be a better
player
and i will do that you know here as well
and being back home
just being able to be with my kids all
the time is
being able to see my mom and dad and and
my wife all the time is to me the best
thing you can ask for kind of being back
home and not having him to have to
travel everywhere um is a blessing for
me
hey russ uh 7 10 espn um a lot of the
new thoughts about how they're excited
to play with you just want to get your
thoughts on the roster this kind of
combination veterans uh obviously lebron
anthony davis your thoughts on the
roster yeah man it's amazing ross is
great a bunch of guys that i've already
known uh previous which is
even better and i'm more excited just to
like i said before man i'm always
interested in my as i come into the
season i'm always looking at the roster
and figuring out how i can make other
guys better and it's as simple as that
and i want to be able to
leave an impact on people when they
either play with me or come across me
and obviously in a positive way and
i'll find ways to do that with our
roster but i'm really looking forward to
getting getting together with all the
guys and then figuring out
okay question for frank um russ kind of
shared a little bit of his vision of how
this might work out over time but i'm
curious what is your vision for how
lebron uh a.d and russell can all work
together and in what ways do you see
each of them maybe needing to adapt
their games for it all to maximize its
fullest potential
yeah well i mean i think any time you
have three great players like this there
is an element of sacrifice uh required
and you know we've all talked about that
and are all in on that
um
but these these three guys can do it all
you know and what i love about our group
braun ada and russ is they're all make
the right play players you know what i
mean it's it's not just about scoring uh
or or being a one once one dimensional
player you know they can all do it all
you know so
i'm most excited about what uh seeing
what the three of them on the court at
the same time looks looks like
i think we're going to be an extremely
dynamic uh fast breaking team and one
that um you know can play uh they can
play off of all three guys in in many
different ways so
um you know i think with the the
athleticism of those guys plus the guys
that the complimentary parts we've we
put together the shooters and the
defenders
um i think we got a real chance this
year to do something special and uh it's
on us now
to put in the work
you know and um if you get these this
type of talented guys
to buy in and put in the work you know
hopefully we can achieve something
special
question for russell and frank as well
much has been made about the age of this
roster
um could that actually be a weapon
something to serve and to your advantage
if we consider that age equals
experience
age does equal experience
iq intelligence helps you win
um
you know and and in terms of motivation
the motivation for us is is that trophy
you know i mean not what people are
saying
um you know this group is is highly
driven uh to get back on top
and um yeah i don't really think about
anything about what anybody's saying
about our age but i do i do agree that
the experience um it will be necessary
and will help us win
yeah
no go ahead
kyle goon again russ i was just
wondering uh you had so so much
stability in oklahoma city for such a
long time and then you've you've been
played for a couple teams the last
couple years does that
change your concept of what you want out
of a franchise and is your vision
and obviously you know there's factors
beyond any one person's control was your
vision to just to be with the lakers for
a long time
my vision uh
you know
in this league you understand this is a
business and
through that you
just do your job and that's what i'll
continue to do as far as the business
side of basketball and figuring out
where i would be and like i couldn't i
wouldn't imagine that i'd be here three
years ago three or four years ago
it's just something that i can't
fathom but
while i'm here i will
that's where i know how give everything
that i have
and i let the business side of
basketball take care of that
well allison's coming up too i want to
thank russell's family and support team
that's here today too and
when i was a agent for james harden i
went to a lot of thunder games early in
his career and russell's dad is going to
be a perfect part of lakers nation
with the energy he brings
we're gonna do some photos
that's perfect bob's gonna officially
introduce russell to the lakers
it is a
official if you will big game i like
that russell westbrook a los angeles
laker
you like that
i do um you know for me having played in
the 80s and to see how
the league has evolved as to you know
players trying to connect
uh to you know collaborate even trying
to win championships and trying to
create that chemistry and you see what's
happened in brooklyn you see what
happened in golden state a few years ago
lebron going to miami so that's cool
that's that's
now uh and and to have russell uh
westbrook at this point in his career
uh you know be added to
uh already dynamic duo in lebron and a.d
and we gave up some young